monarchs bluffs against corruption so
how best to do that
you've seen the marauders
indeed
and we should welcome their presence
here
you should speak with representatives
from each faction and then choose
you wish to learn the secrets that only
the syndicate had the syndicate
why we are the learned ones we use the
razor of logic and the guide of reason
to understand our world
uh
do you seek the glory and riches of
battle
we are the solution to a world in chaos
through strength discipline and
perseverance we will enforce our will
and bring this land
the covenant shares its light with all
so as to in all people there is a spark
an initiative if you will
in some people it burns so brightly that
others feel it
we in the covenant
speak with the factions they're the ones
oh i think so
as rowdy and demanding as they can
sometimes
be you want to make a difference here or
anywhere in eternam it's really the most
efficient way to do so
i see the light of wisdom in you your
righteous path is with the covenant i
can see this as clear as day
we take our vow seriously as members of
the the lost a scourge upon the living
it would bring comfort to the people of
monarchs